Salut, c'est Norman !
Aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de vous faire
une petite vidéo un peu particulière,
parce que j'aime
tout ce qui est particulier.
J'avais envie de vous dessiner
un truc qui s'appelle un "Draw my life".
Le principe est super simple,
il suffit de dessiner sa vie
sur un tableau blanc,
avec des crayons, et puis de le filmer.
En français, on pourrait peut-être
traduire ça par "Ma vie en dessin".
En plus, ça tombe bien, parce que moi,
je sais vraiment bien dessiner. Faux !
Alors, voilà, moi j'ai grandi
ici, dans les favellas.
J'ai passé mon enfance à tirer
avec des putain de guns et—
Ouais, non, en fait,
c'est pas vrai du tout.
Moi, ma vie
est beaucoup plus banale.
Mais je vais vous
la raconter quand même.
Alors, voilà, je m'appelle Norman,
j'ai grandi en France.
Je suis né à Arras,
j'ai grandi à Lens,
précisément à Liévin,
bref, j'ai grandi dans le Nord.
Mes grands-pères étaient mineurs
dans les mines de charbon,
un métier typique du nord
de la France, enfin à l'époque.
On les appelait
les Gueules Noires.
Ouais, même s'ils ne sont pas
vraiment noirs, c'est juste le charbon.
Mes grands-parents et mes parents
ont vécu dans des maisons pour mineurs.
On appelle ça
des corons.
Je suis donc issu d'une famille
typiquement ch'ti.
J'en suis fier,
putain, OK ?!
Ma mère était prof d'histoire-géo
et directrice d'un collège
et mon père était directeur d'un centre culturel
et réalisateur de vidéos institutionnelles.
Bon, là, je les ai fait roux, mais c'est
parce que je n'ai pas d'autre stylo.
Quand j'étais petit, j'avais la particularité d'avoir
une énorme touffe de boucles blondes sur la tête.
♪ La coupe de grand-mère ♪
Sept jours sur sept.
Un vrai plaisir.
Les adultes aimaient bien me dire
"Oh ben, dis donc, on dirait Boucle d'Or !",
alors que les filles de mon âge disaient
"Hé, regardez, on dirait un mouton !"
Parfait ! Ouin !
Du coup, pour pallier à ça,
j'allais super souvent chez le coiffeur,
et quand j'en sortais, les filles de mon âge,
dont j'étais amoureux,
me disaient "Hé, regardez,
on dirait un mouton rasé !".
Ouin !
[Psss, Prout]
Des fois, mon père ramenait à la maison
la grosse caméra de son travail.
Ma sœur et moi, on n'arrêtait pas
de s'amuser avec.
On faisait des petites vidéos marrantes.
Ding ! Hé, Daphné, si on faisait une sex tape ?
J'ai la voix du vieux dans les Simpsons.
Mais Norman, c'est pas possible, voyons, je suis ta sœur.
>> Ça marche !
Oui, j'étais en train de faire
la voix du mec qui mue,
parce que, à cette époque-là, j'étais
une sorte de gros adolescent, qui pue.
Avoir une grande sœur, ça a des avantages,
mais aussi des inconvénients.
Par exemple, ma mère aimait bien recycler
des vêtements de ma sœur en me les faisant porter.
Hé, vas-y, je veux pas,
moi, je suis un garçon.
Moi, j'ai un zizi, OK ?
Mais elle me disait toujours
"Mais Nono, t'inquiètes pas,
ce sont des vêtements mixtes !"
>> OK.
Et puis le lendemain,
j'allais à l'école.
Hé regardez, le mouton,
il a mis une robe. Ha ha ha !
Ha ha ha !
>> Hé, je vous signale que c'est un vêtement mixte, OK !
Enfin, une sorte de robe mixte.
Jetons-lui des pierres ! Ouh !
[ouin, psss, prout]
Après, vers l'âge de 12 ans,
j'ai fait de la musique. J'ai fait du saxophone.
Alors ouais, c'est un instrument
super classe,
mais seulement
quand tu en fais super bien.
Norman, tu peux me jouer
un petit air de saxo ?
Ouais, carrément.
[saxo]
Tu fais trop pitié. Je te supprime
direct de mes amis MSN.
Et j'ai même été scout,
scout catholique de France.
On dirait pas trop un foulard de scout, là,
on dirait plus un stéthoscope.
Bonjour, je suis médecin !
Sauf que quand j'allais chez les scouts,
bah je me faisais taper par les grands.
Hé, vas-y, passes-moi ton foulard !
Et ton béret ! Et ton iPhone !
Ça existe pas encore, bonsoir.
Jusqu'au jour
où ma mère est intervenue.
Hé vous deux, vous lâchez mon fils direct,
sinon je vous démonte hé, zég !
[Tchouf]
Puis un jour, ma mère
s'est faite attraper
par un méchant tueur en série,
qui s'appelle le cancer.
Elle est partie rejoindre les étoiles.
Je suis sûr qu'elle me regarde
de là où elle est.
Ma sœur, mon père et moi,
on est venu s'installer à Paris.
Et ma France est
de plus en plus dégueulasse.
J'ai passé mon bac, avec mention,
pas de mention, et là,
je me suis mis à jouer à un jeu vidéo en ligne,
un MMORPG pendant deux ans non-stop.
Et puis j'ai redoublé.
Et puis j'ai retriplé.
Pendant ces années, j'ai quand même fait
un truc pas mal, c'est que je me suis marié.
Ouais, ça peut paraître bizarre,
mais je me suis marié,
avec une elfe de la nuit.
Je la trouvais super bonne.
Après, j'ai essayé de passer mon permis.
Enfin, j'ai essayé.
Le jour où j'ai passé le permis,
l'inspecteur m'a dit :
Vous êtes le pire conducteur de la planète Terre,
c'est nul à chier, vous êtes un danger public !
Heu, ça veut dire que je l'ai ?
J'ai commencé la vidéo avec
mon meilleur pote Hugo sur Dailymotion.
Heu, attendez, excusez-moi.
Voilà, comme ça.
Ouais, non, en fait,
voilà, comme ça.
Euh non, en fait,
plutôt comme ça.
Non, je rigole !
Ça s'appelait Le Velcrou.
En rapport aux chaussures
avec des velcros.
À l'époque, on trouvait ça stylé.
Et puis on a été rejoint
par notre pote Kemar,
un mec très, très marrant,
avec des très grosses lunettes.
C'est à cette époque qu'on est tombé
par hasard sur d'autres gars,
qui faisaient des vidéos
comme nous sur Dailymotion.
Il y avait Cyprien,
à l'époque Monsieur Dream,
Jérôme Niel,
à l'époque La Ferme Jérôme,
Maxime Musqua, à l'époque
Les Chroniques de la Grosse Pomme,
Jhon Rachid,
à l'époque Mac Gyver du Bled,
et Mister V,
à l'époque Mister V.
Ouais, il faut savoir que là, je l'ai
très, très mal dessiné. Je suis désolé.
Et ceci n'est pas un abat-jour,
c'est un bob.
Et puis, il y avait aussi
Amandine du 38.
[inaudible]
À cette époque,
on était en 2008.
J'aimais tellement ça, faire des vidéos,
que je suis carrément allé à la fac, leur annoncer.
Bonjour, j'arrête la fac. Je me mets
à faire des vidéos sur Internet.
Heu, c'est quoi Internet ?
C'est un sport ?
Comme le badminton ?
Mais c'est aussi à cette époque
que je me suis rendu
dans l'association "Chats des rues",
parce que moi, j'adore les chats.
Depuis tout petit,
j'en ai toujours plein.
Je me rappelle, j'en avais vu un qui était
super beau, roux, avec un style un peu de pirate,
j'avais envie de le prendre,
c'était lui que j'allais prendre,
et puis tout d'un coup,
il s'est mis à [vomir].
Heu, finalement,
je vais prendre lui !
C'était Sergi.
>> Oh non, pourquoi moi ? Je n'ai pas de cerveau !
Et puis un jour, en revenant d'un concours
dans un club de ping-pong, je me suis dit :
Tiens, si je faisais une petite vidéo,
pour raconter ça, mais tout seul cette fois ?
J'ai mis ma vidéo en ligne sur le site YouTube,
et là, j'ai fait le buzz.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je suis
Van Damme ! Je suis aware !
En parallèle à mes vidéos YouTube,
je me suis même mis à faire du one-man-show.
Excatement la même vibe
que dans mes vidéos, mais sur scène.
Certaines personnes me reprochent
de trop souvent remercier mes abonnés,
de trop souvent dire merci
à ceux qui me regardent,
mais ces gens-là ne savent pas,
ils n'imaginent pas
à quel point les internautes
ont changé ma vie.